i was a film director i did a lot of
commercials tv commercials music vid
music video clips i i liked my work very
much but but there was a
a time that i started to understand that
i'm failing to be the great author i
thought i should be i saw myself as
somebody that will actually
his work will mean something
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders let's talk
about energy tech i love energy tech
meet the aron benoon founder and chief
technology officer of nostromo energy
euron is passionate about the
environment and is an activist for the
proper use of natural resources before
co-founding nostromo geron spent several
years in managerial positions at
software companies leading in cleantech
and industrial performance of efficacy
he served in the israeli defense force
air force pilot iran experienced the
importance of a cleaner planet from a
bird's eye view he's trained in
electrical studies and granted a
certificate of energy conservation
master from the israeli ministry of
national infrastructure energy and water
resources
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you
thank you for having me having me yeah
mom of course
i'm really really excited to have you
and i'll tell you why because i've been
thinking a lot about you know the energy
space and the climatetech space a lot of
different players are entering this
market in in the last few years or so as
we're becoming more and more concerned
with what's happening but you know
immediately as you look into your
website you see something that's a
little contrarian and you're saying you
know sustainable energy isn't really
sustainable energy everybody please wake
up and i'm excited to to take these 20
minutes and pick apart your brain and
what you actually mean by that and with
nostromo energy what you're actually
doing there and that's actually going to
make a a major impact both on my life my
kids life my grandkids life so javon
tell me a little bit about nostromo and
and then we'll go back in time and i'm
curious to hear why this is something
that you chose to pursue
all right so um
we are claiming something quite
i think it's like it's obvious it's like
the fundamental um questions that you
should ask yourself about the transition
or the the the possible transition that
we're facing
and this is uh if the stability of the
grid is uh
consists of
i mean the stability of the of the grid
that that is is renewable grid consists
on energy storage
if you know or not i assume you know
that there is no renewable agreed grid
without energy storage because the
nature comes and goes the sun is shining
and whatever you know wind comes in
whatever the instability of natural
resources and
say that if you are going to be
a sustainable electrical electric
generation um
sources
you're going to lean on them you must
have storage so it's the biggest
question since
i would say 2015
summer of 2015 we had the degree parity
that this is a moment in history that
the cost of of solar energy uh went down
and met the cost of of greed
fossil green um and then since then uh
decline like today a solar cost of
energy is like two cents
when the the green cost is about eight
six to eight cents so so that means that
that since the summer of 2015 everybody
that understands something
understood that the future is going to
be solar and wind and clean energy
because of the economic uh scheme not
because uh
regardless
your wishes to stop polluting the
atmosphere so so the biggest question
that came right after it okay so how we
can store solid energy in order to uh
maintain a
stable green so right today as for today
um historically
95 or 93
percent of the available energy storage
is actually done by uh gravitation of
water this is tertiary these are
historical and huge um
energy storage facilities that
that are using a hydraulic pressure of
water and in gums in order to
store uh
water and then produce electricity but
this method of of
you know this this is mountain
you know you take off mountains in order
to build these huge facilities so so
this method was um
i would say exhausted uh and today uh
the
of new installations consist of lithium
ion batteries which are a great solution
for our laptops for our iphones and
cellular and for our cars
but
we
we would challenge this idea if you're
talking about to stabilize the grid
using this form of energy storage it's
electrochemical it has many many
downsides the the biggest downside of
electrochemical energy storage is of
course waste management
nobody really knows today how to recycle
these materials and
we know only to extract some very
expensive materials out of that
batteries but
mainly these batteries will go and be
buried in landfills
and will be treated like nuclear waste
and right we already know we've grown up
through this you know environmental
crisis
that we understand that everything that
goes into land is coming back in our
drinking water
it doesn't go anywhere so we've learned
that through you know we're we're uh
matured
into reality and today
when when when you think about it when
we were
smaller or younger we thought where all
the plastic goes to so there is a great
answer today it goes to the middle of
the pacific we have islands at the size
of texas of of plastic and now let's
deal with this you know amazing huge
disaster now now the big the next
question should be already asked where
does all the lithium goes to and if you
if you're building a future uh consists
of of lithium ion batteries you're
actually portraying a and not not a
sustainable future that will be and and
not sustainable or means use
in order to support sustainable
greed but will
you're actually building the next
environmental crisis so the main
the main
opposition of ours
towards this idea is this is not a clean
idea this is not a great future portrait
with these mountains of lithium and so
we suggest a different way to store
energy which is clean durable safe and
has zero and negative environment impact
that's what we're pursuing
so clean your durable safe and zero
negative impact i mean that's obviously
you know an incredible ideal tell me a
little bit about you know the solution
that you're that you're offering but
then i'm curious to take a step back and
understand from a more entrepreneurial
perspective and leadership perspective
what is it like working in this field
what is it like trying to optimize for
these for these great ideas and then how
do you actually balance that with you
know the economic aspects of building a
great company that you know at the end
aims to make the best returns for its
investors
so so
i must say that
i did not choose
it was not like you know
a logic procedure that i decided to go
into the clean energy
around since i thought yeah that's going
to be great in few years and i should
you know i can grow up there or or
thrive um
i must say that it's 2009 um i had my
own you know career crisis or i would
say
i i was 15 years for
more than 12 years i was a film director
i did a lot of commercials tv
commercials music music video clips i i
liked my work very much but there was a
time that i started to understand that
i'm i'm failing to be the great author i
thought i should be i saw myself as
somebody that will actually
his work will mean something and and
since
that was you know
revealed to me i started to ask myself
what is the actual um
clause that i'm pursuing and what will
be written on my epitaph what will be my
epitaph if you'd like yeah i mean you're
38 years old
i had
my first child
and ready to have my my second
the younger
hallelujah was the uh elder and and i
started to think what is the legacy i
will leave behind me and that will i
mean music video clips or commercial i
mean who cares
so so i had a crisis of of of uh i would
say um
looking back towards uh
more early in my life passionate towards
uh being able to be part of something
that means more
more than the usual every day and and i
decided very
i would say like blindly i i heard about
the solar revolution that started about
2005 2007 it was more and you know it
was more it appeared more and i
understood i understood i could feel
that this revolution is starting and
it's a very interesting one and this is
a tycoon
the way we've treated our environment
and i thought that could be a great
journey to go into
the startup environment
and being
dealing with
how to change the world for the better
so i i pointed you know i i designated
myself towards this arena and i've been
i've done i was working as a marketing
marketing communication manager for one
startup because i was
a director it was easy for me to catch
this position and then i i was a partner
in other startups that did the energy
management for a
producer big producer of big companies
that produce
manufacturers
and then in 2016
i i had this like
um
it was actually a big frustration
because i knew two things or more than
two but not more than three the first
one i knew that air conditioning is the
biggest consumer on the grid i was ex
i was exposed to data i understood the
massive
electricity demands of cooling systems
and how it grows year by year and second
i i understood
that
the need for storage is going to be huge
because of the solar penetration you
know in california today
they are producing
about 16 000 megawatts of capacity of
solar energy the meaning of that it's
like 16 gigawatt it's like it's like a
rock robin if i may say so it's like a
2.7 gigawatt so it's like a taking or
dropping a triple by five or maybe six
and all these
you know power plays are going down at
sunset and disappear vanish as if it you
know
so the the degree that is dealing with
such a flu fluctuation
in the supply must give a great answer
to the to the storage in order to
stabilize
these changes otherwise the grid being
collapsed now today california is
producing only 14.6 or so percent of its
total energy with solar and they have
their goal for 2030 which is nine years
from now to be 50
the meaning of that is that solar
production in california will have to
triple
in the next nine years triple and we are
talking now on on a ramp up on on street
sunset they are losing between 4 000 to
6 000 megawatts every day this is like
wow a crazy situation now so deeper
penetration of solar will have to draw
huge amount of energy storage
and and so the last thing i knew for in
this matrix that
air conditioning is the big user of
electricity on the grid and that the
need for energy storage is going to be
huge and the last thing
is
a simple trivia that water
tap water h2o
aka h2o um it have has the highest
latent heat in nature
okay what does that okay what does that
mean what does that really mean what
does it mean
there is a secret for every material in
nature called latent heat meaning there
is a certain factor
how much this
material can
either
observe or um excel energy while
changing phase
without the temperature changes i'll
give you an example if you heat water
so they don't
boil at 100 degrees centigrade or 212
thousand it's not the true once they
reach this temperature they start to
observe energy without changing the
temperature and actually
the the
phase change into gas
will happen way way low later after they
reach the temperature so this phase it's
called the change phase or latent heat
goes either from from liquid to gas or
from liquid to solid the same it has
different uh
valid
values so water are the strongest
material in
holding and you know um
absorbing energy before it uh
solidified before it becomes you know
the ice
so the simple ice that we know this is
like an amazing way to store cold energy
in the most dense way well only second
to ammonia if i'm but this is really
this this is like
only second to ammonia they are by far
the best material to hold cold energy in
the form of solids so every every time
you see a tube of ice you should know
that this anomaly is crazy and i'll tell
you a secret water has
41 anomalies
wow 41. this is only one of the
anomalies of water which which put water
as the most elenite or the most like
strange material on earth so if you
would think that what are normal there
is totally abnormal behavior
so so i knew about this anomaly so the
next question i ask myself is how come
nobody is is working in order to exactly
so it sounds so trivial now
yeah so you say okay so this is trivial
so so the first thing that an
entrepreneur think is if this is so
trivial i must actually it can be that
i'm the first one to think about it of
course you should be really like crazy
to think that you're the first one so
i'm not i was not i'm not the first ones
they thought about actually
these kind of of systems are in the
market for the last 70 years or so
but wow the market did not embrace these
technologies because of the good reason
because technology was very very
incompatible with the commercial market
meaning this technology that was
introduced for the last few decades uh
it was actually a bulk of big you know
tanks of water that you can actually
make eyes of them big you know bulky ice
[Music]
tanks
and then you can
use it in order to take off your pooling
load
um
and and the reason that nobody is
choosing this almost never unless you
must
for some reason is because of real
estate now i understood that the biggest
consumer customers for this uh solution
should be
real commercial real estate meaning
hotels big office buildings you know
shopping malls hospitals and whatever so
if you are incompatible with the
commercial market you should
bring you know a different technology
that will be much more uh modular much
more the the customer first will will
embrace it this is the biggest challenge
so the first thing we did is to to well
that was my
what i just gave you is that is the
elevator pitch i gave my family and
friends so the first round which is
friends and family
the 2 200 000 i raised well there were
no friends in it only family
it's it's my sisters
and then my brother and then my parents
they came in and said okay you know it's
crazy
i i'm not an engineer even i'm not i'm
not a scientist but i took the this
fault of the crazy scientist that says
look this is
inconceivable i mean how come nobody is
doing that this is crazy and they were
convinced for the need so so the first
thing was convincing my um
surrounding with the need that the need
is going to be amazingly huge so they
say and i told them you know it can't be
too complicated i mean to freeze a lot
of ice in a way that will be compatible
to the commercial arena and and could be
you know utilized in a way that won't
take too much real estate of course i
was wrong it was not that simple so it
took us a few years to solve to um to
develop the ice brick or basically you
know
ice battery if you
or the building block of our system and
then we understood much more about this
arena and the the landscape and so we we
head to
confront other
technological barriers and the
challenges we which we have already
confirmed confronted
our system today is matured and is
working it has great you know
performance and and that took about five
million
dollars
and
until this day we already
invested or
put into our research and
like eight i would i would suggest like
eight million dollars and then we we
just finished a marriage so we are and
we just
we um
and we were founded with 13 million
dollars uh
so all together we are now founded about
20 million dollars and we are now
publicly traded so this is not a
recommendation to buy our stock i cannot
recommend to buy our stock so please put
this disclaimer i cannot recommend to
buyers stock so this is not a
recommendation please
yellow and i think it's such an
inspiring story and you know both from
the legacy personal perspective of you
know you're doing something you're
successful at it and you're saying well
what actually what is my legacy and why
why am i here and what kind of world do
i want to leave behind me and then not
just
think about it but actually act on it
and the first thing is you know getting
your family on board and and realizing
that there's this opportunity here in
the market that wait why why is nobody
else working on this and a lot of other
people are much more knowledgeable than
i am but but going ahead and actually
doing it and making it into a publicly
traded company uh with with millions of
dollars in funding and i think that
that's just an incredible story for
every young entrepreneur and anybody
thinking to be an entrepreneur and
really anybody thinking of what kind of
problem they want to solve so you want
thank you for the inspiration both on
the on the entrepreneurial level but
also on the level of making the world a
better place and thinking outside of the
box about the world and how to do and i
have one last question for you before i
i thank you one last time what are two
or three words that you would use to
describe yourself if you have to think
about yourself you know from a third
person perspective what kind of words
would you choose
um i would say that i'm uneasy
so
yeah i mean
you should be a little bit crazy you
should have some kind of ocd
of uh you should be a little bit miguel
man you know you should think that you
the world is waiting for you to say
something in order to be an entrepreneur
otherwise i mean don't go there you know
you should be a little bit personal
yeah i mean so so so i think that
what characterized me the most is that i
i
like a child
i'm in awe i'm i'm i'm really like
it's it's crazily getting bigger as long
as i'm more mature like the big
questions are unanswered
the great you know life uh journey
is just revealing it itself is more
mysterious and i think that
that you know everybody is interested in
you know high physics understand that
our reality is like just like you know
one
uh side of the story and there is other
things going around which are totally
crazy and i'm not talking only about
shredding their shredded trading their
kid
cat sorry
yeah schredinger cat i'm not talking
only about him although i'm i have my
feelings thought about this cat i'm
talking about everything around you know
this is just
i understand that i know as as as i'm
growing up i know less and less and and
and i stay you know like i said in awe
i'm amazed
to be you know
to be in this story alive
so i would say that if you if you if
you're lacking uh this curiosity and and
passion towards you know
studying and learning
i wouldn't suggest you will go to to be
an entrepreneur if you're
um
if you're curious enough to to to go
into the to to
be able to um to walk through
the fire um
and know that there is a big bigger
purpose to everything you you're doing
and try to concentrate on purposes that
has
i would say a good meaning and i would
say go for it don't do anything else
thank you very very much this is
wonderful best of luck with the rest of
the journey and with what you're doing
and and i can't wait to see the other
things that you'll do and the
inspiration that you will leave for
others definitely an amazing legacy
thank you very much and thank you very
much
[Music]